we know less and we understand left of
the world around us than any person
doesn't know that you know the the
evidence can even imagine we live
entirely within a microscopic section of
the stimuli that are possible and it
flood in on us all the time let me give
you an example we think we see
everything but we only see the
electromagnetic radiation across a
litter almost literally Mike relatively
microscopic section of the entire
spectrum you know run it running from
ultra low frequency radiation to granel
radiation this vast array we read we can
we get and we can understand only a tiny
tiny fraction we're not aware of that
other other animals in the world can
read infrared and they can't see others
can't see red and some move primarily
directed by ultraviolet and so on
and we don't know exactly what else is
out there we know that a number of
organisms use echolocation bats of the
familiar example others or echolocate
with electrical impulses they broadcast
from their bodies like electric fish and
electric eels we have no sense of that
whatsoever and yet bats for example can
maneuver with fantastic speed and
accuracy with just using echo locations
from their own voices but that's just
the beginning
we are completely ignorant or unknowing
except when we discover it by
instruments of the magnetic field of the
earth
birds birds migrate with it many species
do the entire world of electrical
perception we sense electricity and
electric flow only by maybe a sound that
it creates or a sense of strange sense
of vibration and comfort on us other
organisms use it all the time but most
of all is important of all is that we
are among the few creatures in the world
as live in a primarily audio-visual
world
birds are another example that's why we
love them so perhaps part of the reason
we love them so because they're using
the same channels we are and humans when
you think about it communicate and they
see and they understand almost entirely
with hearing and sight we are miserable
when it comes to taste and smell and I
don't care how exquisite are the finest
restaurant squid and cuisines of New
York's restaurants we still only sense a
tiny fraction of what most of the animal
world is sensing they live by pheromones
they it means that they communicate by
chemical smell and taste and they can
communicate in a complex manner in this
way for example in my work which I began
in the late 50s with natural products
chemists I and others found out that an
answer committing a communicating by
pheromones and that actually they have
tend to according to species 10 to 20
substances that they use to smell and
taste in organizing their societies we
have no sense of that whatsoever no you
know what
of knowing when what they're doing we
just see them running around they look
like they're little particles and
Brownian movement you know or forming
lines and so on with those 10 to 20
pheromones they use they can vary
meaning greatly about by how much of a
pheromone they released sometimes they
release it only in billionth of a gram
to send a signal by the context I mean
where it's released and in what
situation the social situation gives
another meaning and in combination so
it's almost like sentences being formed
an ant that's leaving the nest and it is
alarmed can release different
concentrations that communicate words
like or what we would call words pay
attention pay attention attention
attention come in this direction a
problem a problem a situation
opportunity come and then when it gets
to high concentration if it's one of
their alarms something
it is attack attack attack anything that
moves let's not have the colony smell
then oh it's a worker coming in home
with a rescued larva step aside step
aside help clean it help clean it you
know it just goes on forever but the
point is that there are worlds out there
from bacteria to social insects and on
to the mammal many of the mammals that
are operating with pheromones and we
have only the barest understanding
ourselves and we've done it through
natural products chemistry and
experiments of just what all these
creatures are saying to each other we
live all the time especially in nature
in great clouds of pheromones they're
coming out in spoons of millions of
that can travel for maybe a kilometer
before they attract individuals in alarm
substances the scent of predators and
the scent of the predator of prey of
extreme as extremely low levels and
since there are so many species living
together in a natural system for example
18,000 species live together and we now
know in the Smoky Mountain National Park
of plants and animals and bacteria and
so on we're just beginning to understand
how the natural world works and a large
part of it is that it lives in another
world from the one we do it's a
pheromone world